bonjour à tous et bon week-end un
week-end qui a commencé très tôt cette
nuit par le dénouement d'une affaire
policière que vous avez certainement
tous suivi au mois d'octobre dernier
l'enlèvement de la petite sophie dugué
michel faut que l'homme que les
policiers soupçonnaient depuis le
premier jour a été arrêté et cela s'est
passé dans le jardin de son ami thérèse
le marbre à bertry dans le nord faut que
était bien le ravisseur de sophie dugué
cela ne fait aucun doute au moment de
son arrestation il avait en poche
trente mille francs en billets de 500
francs les billets de la rançon de un
million versé par le père de la petite
sophie dugué françois cornet nous allons
voir maintenant donc un peu en détail
les circonstances de cette arrestation
qui s'est passé en pleine nuit en pleine
nuit ils étaient environ une heure du
matin et le dicton cherchez la femme se
confirme une fois de plus en effet la
cavale du ravisseur de sophie dugué a
pris fin à quelques kilomètres seulement
quelques mètres seulement de la maison
de thérèse le marbre c'est alors qu'ils
cherchaient à pénétrer dans le jardin
comme vous venez de nous le dire qu'il a
été appréhendé par les policiers de
lille michel fau que réussit cependant à
s'échapper à l'étreinte des policiers
qu'il avait ceinturé ceci le rattraper
rapidement sur lui il devait retrouver
environ 35 milles francs en coupures de
500 francs au domicile de thérèse le
marbre les policiers ont retrouvé la
quasi totalité de la somme de la rançon
il est gâchée dans la baignoire de
thérèse le marbre cette affaire remonte
on s'en souvient au 24 octobre dernier
cette fillette la fillette de 3 ans
sophie dugué fille de riche fermier de
saint bandry était retrouvée était
d'enlever je veux dire alors qu'elle
s'apprêtait à rentrer de l'école avec sa
bonne il était 17 heures environ
un homme avait surgi d'une déesse arrêté
au bord de la route après avoir
littéralement arraché l'enfant des mains
de sa bonne le ravisseur avait démarré
quelques mètres plus loin il avait
déposée sur le bord de la route une
feuille de papier en majuscules sans une
faute d'orthographe
l'inconnue indiqué sa volonté de
recevoir une rançon d'un million de
nouveaux francs précisant que ni la
police ni la presse ne devraient être
informés c'est vraisemblablement cette
lettre
a perdu pour que car elle a été analysée
par les graphologues dans l'après midi
du samedi 25 octobre
monsieur dugué lançait un appel ne fait
pas de mal à l'enfant
nous sommes prêts à payer la rançon par
tous les moyens à votre convenance nous
ne ferons rien pour vous faire arrêter
quelques heures plus tard le père de la
petite sophie échappant à la sagacité
des journalistes déposer le millions
demandés en coupures de 500 francs dont
les numéros avait été relevé un endroit
situé à un kilomètre de soissons le 28
octobre entre 3 et 4 heures du matin
sophie dugué été retrouvé en parfaite
santé dans une trois chevaux volet
arrêté devant la porte du commissariat
de police de soissons
dès lors la police avait le feu vert une
enquête était ouverte et menée sans
désemparer dans toute la région
les recherches entreprises conduisent
les enquêteurs tout d'abord vers un
suspect habitant compiègne monsieur sai
bouziane anciens harkis propriétaire
d'une ds mais bouziane et rapidement mis
hors de cause et libéré après quelques
heures de détention
le soir du 28 octobre le procureur de la
république remet à la presse la copie du
message laissé par leurs ravisseurs de
la petite sophie dugué
de son côté la police publie la liste
des billets deux larrons sont numérotées
le 31 octobre séibou diané de nouveau
entendu par la police
dans le même temps en prêtant suppose
que faut que et bien le ravisseur de la
petite sophie et on appréhende thérèse
le marbre elle est emmenée par la police
deux jours plus tard une fois l'empêcher
faut que de communiquer avec elle et de
mettre en difficulté les techno motif de
l'inculpation complicité dans l'évasion
de guichen faut que la prison de cambrai
en juillet 69 quelques jours plus tard
et les rendus à ses trois enfants dans
la nuit de noël
le ravisseur est cool tous les billets
de la rançon quelques billets de la
rançon et une nouvelle piste est lancé
contre lui aucune décision n'est encore
prise au sujet du transfert de michel
fau que à soissons il est actuellement
interrogé par la police au commissariat
de caudry où on peut apprendre que selon
les premières déclarations il aurait agi
seul
par ailleurs il se serait rendu
épisodiquement en belgique et aurait
vécu la plupart du temps dans un bois à
la limite des départements du nord et de
l'aisne
de là ils rendaient parfois visite à
thérèse le madr son ami à leur domicile
de berti c'est tout ce que nous savons
pour l'instant vous et policiers sont en
train de terminer leurs enquêtes et je
pense que ce soir il y aura d'ailleurs
une conférence de presse en août au
ministère de l'intérieur au cours de
laquelle nous apprendrons
tous les détails sur la façon dont faut
que a été arrêté cette conférence de
presse en effet a eu lieu ce soir en
direct sur notre plateau nous aurons
monsieur gévaudan directeur de la police
judiciaire qui nous racontera un détail
les circonstances de l'arrestation de
michel foucault et un dernier détail
faut que a été arrêté c'est bien lui
l'auteur de l'enlèvement il n'y a pas de
doute combien risque-t-il quelle peine
il risque en principe environ 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle en effet si
l'article 355 du code pénal prévoit que
le coupable d'un enlèvement de mineurs
dont le but se faire payer une rançon
est passible de la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité et de la peine capitale
si le rapt a été suivi de la mort de la
victime ce texte précise ensuite que la
sanction sera de 10 à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle si la victime a été
retrouvée vivante après que soit rendu
l'arrêt de la condamnation
c'est notamment le cas de la sphère
sophie dugué tout à fait ça eh bien nous
allons passer à la politique étrangère
la plaine déjà est-ce que cela vous dit
quelque chose
eh bien oui souvenez-vous on en parlait
beaucoup il ya deux ans c'est au laos et
c'est le champ de bataille préféré des
princes qui se disputent le pays on
l'avait un peu oublié c'est ainsi le
vietnam accaparé l'attention dans cette
région du monde
et puis brusquement cette nuit les
forces pro communistes ont attaqué les
troupes régulières du prince ou vannes à
foum après deux heures de bataille la
plaine des jarres tout entière est
tombée aux mains des assaillants ainsi
que l'aérodrome de sienne situé à 275 km
2 vietnam de vientiane la capitale
nous espérons pouvoir vous montrer ce
soir des images des combats mais voyons
d'abord comment se présenter la
situation au laos avant l' attaque de
cette nuit serge peter hayes
il faudrait presque une leçon d'histoire
et géographie pour comprendre ce qui se
passe au laos petit état sans débouché
sur la mer mais ayant des frontières
communes avec six pays asiatiques dont
la république populaire de chine au nord
la république démocratique du vietnam et
le sud vietnam la fameuse piste hautes
cimes et une passe par le laos le long
de la corde dit rana mythique c'est la
piste qu'empruntent hommes et matériel
transitant entre le nord vietnam et les
régions contrôlées par le gpr au sud
vietnam depuis longtemps l'aviation
américaine déversent des milliers de
tonnes de bombes sur ce qu'elle croit
être la piste hô chi minh
mais apparemment
sans grand résultat quant à la guerre
oubliée du laos on peut dire en
schématisant bien sûr que c'est en fait
la guerre du vietnam qui déborde que
c'est un phénomène de contagion
ces scènes de guerre ont été filmées il
ya quelques jours au sud vietnam tout
près de la frontière laotienne colaus
même la guerre larvée qui menaçait de
s'étendre depuis longtemps appris ces
jours derniers des proches les
proportions d'un conflit ou du moins
d'une grande bataille après une
offensive de dix jours deux régiments
communistes se sont emparés ce matin à
la plaine des jarres de l'aérodrome de
qian tang du quartier général des forces
royales laotienne ces dernières
rappelons le s'était installé dans la
plaine des jarres il ya un an
la contre-offensive des forces
communistes et donc une riposte à
retardement car la présence de forces
royales non loin de la frontière nord
vietnamienne pourrait être considérée
par la gauche comme une menace
permanente ces forces de gauche on ne
sait comment les nommer pour le prince
souverain a flu mae pour les américains
il s'agit tout simplement de nord
vietnamiens mais le pathet lao mouvement
communiste n'a aussi assure que ce sont
ses forces à lui il ya une dizaine de
jours les américains avaient mis de gros
avions de transport à la disposition du
gouvernement laotien pour évacuer
quelques quinze mille civils de la
plaine des jarres vieillards femmes
enfants et paysans pêle-mêle il
s'agissait de transformer la plaine déjà
en une zone de libre bombardement est
d'ailleurs sitôt après cette évacuation
400 bombardier américain a déversé un
tapis de bombes sur la région pour
tenter d'enrayer l'avancée des
communistes
ce matin on déclare dans la capitale de
vientiane qu'ils allaient d'une
évacuation et non pas d'une déroute
les forces royales se sont repliés sur
les hauteurs qui entoure la plaine des
jarres il y aura sans doute encore des
combats car aux dernières nouvelles des
avions américains basés au sud vietnam
sont intervenus pour essayer de stopper
l'avancée des communistes en ce qui
concerne le proche orient à suivre à
amman la négociation qui s'engage entre
le roi hussein de jordanie et les chefs
des commandos palestiniens installés
dans son pays la partie est difficile
pour le roi qui va sans doute être
contraint s'il veut sauver son trône
d'annuler les mesures qu'il avait prises
pour limiter la circulation des
commandos palestiniens en jordanie
le leader palestinien yasser arafat est
rentré hier de moscou spécialement pour
participer à cette négociation
le roi hussein de son côté a reçu
l'appui des chefs des principales tribus
bédouines
mais cela risque de ne pas être
suffisant pour s'opposer aux exigences
des palestiniens
chicago usa les cinq pacifiste accusé
d'avoir organisé des émeutes lors de la
convention démocrate de 1968 ont été
condamnés hier au maximum cinq ans de
prison
plus une amende de 5000 dollars soit
25000 francs de nos francs lourd de
violentes manifestations ont éclaté d'un
bout à l'autre des états unis pendant
toute la journée de jeudi en signe de
protestation contre les verdicts rendus
mercredi à chicago
concernant cinq des sept personnes
poursuivies pour incitation à la
violence pendant la convention du parti
démocrate en 1968 en revanche monsieur
spiro agnew vice président des états
unis a félicité les juges hoffman et les
jurys qui ont condamné les cinq hommes à
cinq ans de prison et à des amendes de
5000 $ en déclarant que ce jugement
frappé des anarchistes et des inadaptés
sociaux
la manifestation la plus nombreuse et la
plus violente s'est déroulé à boston où
environ 5000 jeunes gens ont défilé dans
les rues malgré l'interdiction des
autorités
en dispersant les manifestants à coups
de matraques les policiers ont procédé à
une douzaine d'arrestations
tandis que l'on comptait de nombreux
blessés de part et d'autre
enfin new york 26 responsables du parti
démocrate ont manifesté leur volonté
d'entamer une procédure afin d'obtenir
l'annulation du verdict
la veuve du pasteur martin luther king
fille nobel de la paix apôtre de la
non-violence assassiné il ya deux ans
aux états unis
sa veuve est à paris et elle a tenu hier
une conférence de presse pour présenter
le livre qu'elle vient d'écrire ma vie
avec martin luther king vous ne pensez
pas que les méthodes qu'il a préconisé
de non violence soient dépassées
aujourd'hui pour atteindre à l'égalité
raciale aux états unis
nos méthodes non violentes sont
efficaces dans notre lutte pour
l'égalité raciale mais nous luttons pour
les noirs mais aussi pour tous les
déshérités qu'il soit mexicain
portoricain dyens blanc depuis la mort
de mon mari nous avons poursuivi la
lutte c'est grâce à lui grâce à son
action non violente que nous nous
sentons aujourd'hui tous plus forts et
plus unis
c'est grâce à la non violence que nous
sommes efficaces c'est par elle que le
mouvement pour la paix la paix au
vietnam notamment après une telle
extension
seule la non-violence nous permet de
faire pression sur le gouvernement pour
mettre fin à la guerre su persuader que
la violence ne peut pas changer une
société que la violence ne paye pas
et cette beauté semaine en france
l'actualité politique est assez réduite
pendant ce week-end sachez tout de même
que les trains roulent normalement de
nouveau c'est une bonne nouvelle si vous
avez un voyage d'affaires en province et
d'autre part seuls les cheminots
d'avignon sont encore en grève mais on
pense que ça ne durera pas le sont les
seuls à noter aussi le tribunal
administratif de nice a annulé les
élections municipales de corte en corse
vous souvenez sans doute que le 1er
février à corte il y avait eu plus de
votants que d'inscrits sur les listes
électorales l'annulation n'est donc pas
une surprise
un accident de la route dont on parlera
johnny hallyday et sylvie vartan l'ont
échappé belle en effet le chanteur a
manqué un virage dans la traversée du
village de retz près de belfort et sa
voiture a fini contre un mur johnny et
sylvie sont blessés mais il n'y a rien
de grave
ils ont déjà pu rentrer à paris ce matin
et sylvie vartan avait pris place hier
pour se rendre à besançon un gala
l'accident s'est produit aux environs de
20h30 sur la route nationale 83 près
d'europe dans le territoire de belfort
ils ont été aussitôt transporté à
l'hôpital de belfort où notre
correspondant en riches mythe s'est
entretenu avec le chanteur commence à
penser l'accident il a appelé son épouse
de là et vous étiez combien dans la
voiture aux hétéros musiciens vous étiez
avec city barons ont été
5 et vous qui vous avez vous à les
suivre au nez oui bon bah c'est pas
grave et votre bras et civique a pas
grand chose non plus un peu sur le
visage aussi nommément il presque rien
de 2,3 et gratuit et la voiture
heureusement qu'on n'est pas trop du
socle a rendu nerveux dans la nuit
johnny hallyday et sa femme ont pu
regagner paris par le train oui il avait
tout de même passé quelques heures à
l'hôpital m'enfin je voulais dit n'y a
rien de très grave
johnny le nez un peu abîmée et sylvie a
aussi une plaie à la tête mais sans
profondeur aux lèvres je crois c'est ça
ta quai alexandre nous allons parler
annonce nous ont parlé sport d'abord
avec patrick chapuis j'allais oublier
les spurs étaient très grave il ya peu
de choses ont failli et même du ski et
du tennis puisque cela rend plus de ce
qui aujourd'hui à jackson hole aux états
unis c'est le pays de la conquête de
l'ouest c'est karl schranz et michel
jacquot vont tenter de conquérir
définitivement leur premier place dans
la coupe de ski alpin mais patrick
russel second à deux points seulement de
chance va tenter de dépasser
l'autrichien et surtout d'oublier ses
déboires de val gardena première épreuve
aujourd'hui la descente hommes qui aura
lieu tout à l'heure exactement à 19
heures en france and stop c'est mal
comme mein australien qui a réalisé le
meilleur temps à 103 km heure de moyenne
les autres temps derrière dans l'ordre
sont les meilleurs sons soul l'autriche
à cordes in des français hors celle du
vieillard et pinel tennis une surprise
dans l'open des états unis relève heures
le numéro un mondial a été éliminé par
un égyptien qui s'appelle ismael el che
a fait c'est un joueur de 22 ans qui
disputait son deuxième tournoi
professionnel tierces et enfin pas de
forfait demain à auteuil
il y aura dix neuf partants dans le prix
hydravion j'ai terminé pour les squares
hier cyril chapuis tacler alexandre nous
allons parler un peu pâture tout le
monde se souvient du grand succès
qu'avait obtenu à paris l'an dernier
l'exposition vermeer à l'orangerie mais
je crois qu'on revient de nouveau aux
flamands absolument je crois que les
organisateurs ont été encouragés par le
succès de vernon
renier ils ont organisé pour cette année
une exposition sur l'art flamand avoue
jean-pierre enquiries 7 au musée de
l'orangerie toujours à paris que s'ouvre
l'exposition danseurs à permettent 200
peintures 50 dessins des sculptures
appartenant à 18 artistes
il représente l'école flamande 2881 1940
école qui comme le rappelle monsieur
hasard tu éminent critique d'art belge
s'est développée parallèlement à celle
de marque
les français sont venus à bruxelles
nombreux d'ailleurs fan clocks ehsan
lautrec les autres et bien et bel sont
allés à paris
seulement ce qui est intéressant est ce
qui est joue 3 peut intéresser le public
fait qu' il n'y a pas eu d' influence
directe chacun est resté en quelque
sorte sur sa manière de voir le miracle
de van eyck de bruegel devant dix coups
de rubens s'est-il perpétuée jusqu'à nos
jours
madame adhémar conservateur de
l'orangerie répond 800 hésité mais
reconnaît que pour beaucoup de visiteurs
cette exposition se parer d'un délire
que la flamande en sort permeke soit
méconnue des français
mais la jeune génération j'ai su
persuader ne connais pas bien ni en sort
même ce grand peintre qui a été vraiment
une révolution aussi bien pour la france
est que pour l'art belge james heures en
fait deux mines cette exposition
en 1886 déjà il peignait cette toile qui
préfigure bonnart
mais c'est dans son oeuvre la plus
célèbre entrée du christ à bruxelles
quand sort a mis toute sa fougue son
leiris ou toute sa fantaisie
avec wouters c'est la lumière et la joie
de vivre
ses sculptures aussi bien que sa
peinture témoigne de son extraordinaire
vitalité
vandenbergh lui s'inscrit dans la
tradition flamande de bosch et
s'abandonne aux sollicitations de
l'imaginaire
permet qu'enfin admirable dessinateur
apporterait à lui seul s'il le fallait
la preuve de la persistance du génie de
la clim
il ya un an le parlement a voté la loi
sur l'utilisation des contraceptifs
c'est pourquoi la clinique sans nous
avons pensé que c'était le moment après
donc de faire une enquête
pourquoi un peu où en étaient les choses
vous avez fait une enquête au planning
familial tu es sage et très content que
vous me posiez cette question car on a
souvent tendance à croire que planning
familial on ne parle que de construction
horse d'absolument faut c'est un des
problèmes abordés par les personnes du
planning familial et il faut bien savoir
qu'on parle beaucoup du planning
familial on dit on devra y aller il faut
que nous ayons etc
on ne sait pas exactement ce que c'est
ce qu'on y apprend et les conseils qu'on
vous y donne voici un reportage de
france vérité ces femmes ces couples
réunis dans sept salles d'attentes sont
quelques-uns des cent mille adhérents
des 252 centre du mouvement français
pour le planning familial répartis dans
toute la france
il/elle la branche française d'une
fédération internationale dont le centre
est à londres
son but contribuer à la prise de
conscience de la responsabilité du
couple devant la naissance d'un enfant
donné l'adresse alors au fond peu
souffrez-vous savoir précisément connues
sur tout dans le grand public pour son
action en faveur de la contraception de
la régulation des naissances depuis
quelques temps il a pris une orientation
un peu différente
il se propose une étude des problèmes de
la maternité de la natalité et de leurs
répercussions familiale sociale et
nationale
il poursuit la recherche des
informations scientifiques ainsi qu'une
action en faveur de l'information et de
l'éducation qui peut contribuer pour une
bonne part au développement harmonieux
de la famille ceci bien sûr dans le
respect de la liberté de chacun
d'assumer les responsabilités de sa vie
sexuelle et affective
le planning familial à de nombreuses
activités
c'est ainsi par exemple que des
conseillers d'information sexuelle
des médecins du collège médical du
planning familial répondre à toutes les
demandes de conférences et d'animations
de groupe
les assistantes comme ici sont chargés
de recevoir et d'informer chacun qu'ils
soient jeunes ou moins jeunes mariés ou
non mais le planning familial offre
également des consultations de conseil
juridique vous veniez ce soir les
consultations du cac nique familial et
qui la discrète de vous demander
pourquoi
et bien c'est un petit peu discret
évidemment enfin si le fait que mon mari
m'a abandonnée et j'ai eu des problèmes
à résoudre
en doublant je n'avais pas beaucoup de
connaissances et j'ai rencontré enfin
une personne qui était conseillère
conjugale qui m'a conseillé de fuir au
plein et qui va donner l'adresse de la
rue julien c'est la première fois que
vous venez fille non c'est pas la
première fois ça fait déjà un an que je
suis un fils y est liée aussi ici des
conseillères familiale wii ou austin il
est défini à voir les conseillères
familiales sont des assistants qui ont
bien sûr prolonger leur formation pour
pouvoir être apte à recevoir les
personnes qui en font la demande des
traités sur le plan de leurs conflits
conjugaux
sur le plan des problèmes sexuels sur le
plan d'eau
de tout ce qui est au niveau des
relations entre les personnes et la
conseillère reçoit ces personnes pour
essayer de les aider à prendre
conscience de leur situation à éclairer
leurs problèmes à les aider dans la
mesure du possible à devenir plus adulte
c'est à dire être capable de justement
de faire mieux face aux problèmes qui se
présentent à eux
nous avons un rôle assez difficile à
c'est à définir par rapport à ce qui
existe déjà
c'est à dire par rapport aux
psychologues par rapport aux psychiatres
psychanalystes nous sommes évidemment
n'avons pas la même formation
mais nous aidons les gens selon un style
un peu différent et bien entendu notre
travail se fait aussi en collaboration
avec ses différents spécialistes
auxquels les gens on t'a peuvent
s'adresser selon le moment de se trouver
peuvent choisir justement quelquefois de
après avoir une conseillère de devoir un
autre spécialiste ou alors la démarche
est inverse
il y avait beaucoup de personnes tout à
l'heure dans la salle détente et
pourtant aucune où pratiquement aucune
n'a voulu répondre à mes questions
à quoi cela peut il correspondre à votre
avis bien je pense que les gens restés
que je porte quel de problème il ya les
gens qui entendent maintenant de plus en
plus parler enfin de sexualité de pilule
de contraception
on en parle beaucoup en ce moment par
exemple on peut en parler à la radio
dans les journaux en parlent jour par
exemple de l'érotisation delà de la
publicité bon ce sont des choses qui
semblent entrées dans les moeurs
et finalement on s'aperçoit que ce n'est
pas aussi simple que cela et que
beaucoup de personnes enfin pense que
c'est encore un sujet qui est à bout et
que elles ne peuvent pas parler devant
des caméras d'une question qui leur
semble encore très personnel est entouré
de
peut-être d'un certain mystère en tout
cas peut-être aussi d'une certaine
culpabilité
madame audibert secrétaire générale du
planning familial pour la région
parisienne a connu une folle et lien n'a
jamais les malthusiens le planning
familial n'a jamais été contre les
familles nombreuses
lorsque les parents désirent beaucoup
d'enfants le planning familial estime
que chaque couple doit pouvoir décider
du nombre d'enfants qu'ils désirent
la pilule est très contestée
actuellement est ce que vous observez
une certaine perturbation parmi les
femmes qui viennent vous voir
oui ces derniers temps nous avons eu en
tout cas en particulier pas mal de coups
de téléphone de personnes prenant des
pilules et un petit peu affolés par tous
contents disait dans la presse nous les
renvoyons toujours vers leur médecin
nous estimons qu'il ne faut pas
s'affoler inutilement mais vous savez qu
au planning la pilule n'est pas la seule
méthode contraceptive que nous
préconisons et l'avenir du planning
familial
l'avenir dépend des décrets
d'application qui vont paraître
incessamment paraît-il il est question
de créer des centres d'information
familiale nous espérons y avoir notre
place
ça dépend du gouvernement propose de
planning de naissance au souvenez de
chichi la connexion et oui vous n'avez
pas géant femelle du zoo de londres on
avait voulu marier une fois avec un
fouet un panda mâle qui s'appelait anne
années qu'on avait fait venir exprès de
moscou puis ça n'avait pas marché du
tout bien son histoire navrante mais qui
vient d'avoir une conclusion chiche et
ou même tombée amoureuse d'un homme
sauvage cette fois ci s'appelle ben
quelle idée et nous ne venons pas sortir
des histoires dan puisque nous allons
voir quelques extraits d'un film de jean
canal lan de diglee à rat noir je vous
le dis comme je le pense monsieur le
maire helman ça s'envole pas vous parler
toujours du pouvoir du pouvoir ici le
pouvoir c'est vous et vous n'avez jamais
trouvé mon âme ya une chose que je
voudrais vous demander jean canal on
vous connaît beaucoup comme auteur de
feuilleton à la radio à la télévision et
on a l'impression de vous découvrir
comme réalisateur mais ce que c'est une
vraie découverte ou bien ce que vous
n'êtes pas déjà un homme d'image
oui je suis un vieil homme d'imagés pas
qu'il n'y aura que le public qui me
découvre ya parce que je n'ai fait que
revenir mes premiers amours
je sais famous et anne capitaine
simonpieri mais si vous comptez sur cet
incident pour influencer le village de
contre moi et prendre la mairie aux
prochaines élections vous avez par ici à
s'il ya le fascisme ne passera pas
disons que c'est à la fois content comme
pourrait être un conte de daudet ou une
très bonne histoire à la pagnol
mais avec quelque chose de très
particulier à la corse c'est à dire une
certaine violence beaucoup de soleil
vous voulez vous secrets saint joseph le
père du bon dieu je crois il était monté
sur un âne je vois pas le rapport
ils m'ont dit en personne sur le tueur
et le petit jésus dans la crèche
j'avais un ami pour lui tenir chaud et
tu nous manque le petit jésus
il en avait un vous qui êtes l'heureux
nous a fait du petit jésus pourquoi vous
n'intervenez pas après tout cette année
c'est la brebis égarée de l'image i want
me dit oh toi tu vas pas me sortir toute
l'histoire cinq noms 6ème premier récit
c'est toi depuis touché que fait sa
première communion
quand j'ai fait du mieux à la messe
jamais je n'y ai jamais vu
tu prends autant pas vrai et aujourd'hui
ses besoins futurs et eva suture est lui
aussi très longtemps alors monsieur le
curé en fin de compte ce pas
c'est bien le diable ou piquionne et que
la paix soit avec vous mes enfants il ya
tout ce qui constitue un conte
ensoleillé un apologue ensoleillé il y a
une grande tendresse une certaine
caricature des gens il faut frapper au
nous avons deux députés il faut frapper
encore plus haut il n'y a qu'une
solution il faut toucher jérôme
moracchini un ministre de la marine
il n'ya qu'un homme encore qu'ils
puissent toucher 0 moratti un seul en
cause
un vrai le nord de mon pays que le sang
dans le pays où je suis né
eh bien les milliers terminé merci de
votre attention au revoir